فرق الانقاذ التركيه من اخراج فتاه تبلغ
من العمر 17 عاما من تحت انقاض مبنى في
ولايه كهرما مراد جنوبيه تركيا ومع ارتفاع
عدد القتلى الى اكثر من 36 الفا قالت
السلطات ان عمليات البحث والانقاذ اكتملت
في خمس ولايات الجديد نتابعه من مدينه
نورداغ في غازي عنتاب مع مراسلنا المعتز
بالله حسن المعتز تفضل
نعم في مدينه نورداغ هناك
بات مئات الخيام موجوده في هذه المنطقه
مثل التي نحن فيها هذه المدينه تعرضت
لاضرار كثيره جراء الزلزال ربما الصوره
هنا يمكن ان تريكم حجم
الخيام الموجوده في هذه المنطقه حجم
الحياه هنا المساعدات التي تاتي هذه
المدينه طبعا بحسب المعلومات التي حصلنا
عليها سيتم هدها بالكامل واعاده انشائها
سواء كان ذلك في نفس المكان بعد دراسه
بنيه ارضها او في مناطق اخرى طبعا هذه
هذا الوضع في نورداغ هو يشبه كثيرا ما
يحدث في مناطق اخرى ومدن اخرى هناك اكتمال
لعمليه البحث والانقاذ في كل من ملاطيا
وعثمانيه وكلس
عدد المواطنين الاتراك وغير الاتراك
من المناطق المنكوبه يزيد على
عنه
شخص وهذا عدد كبير طبعا مدينه نورداغله
لوحدها كان فيها قبل الزلزال اكثر من 40
الف شخص يقتنها هناك محاولات عده لمساعده
الذين خرجوا من بيوتهم وتضررت بيوتهم على
الاقامه من هذه المحاولات الخيمه التي
نراها هناك ايضا حاويات معدنيه ولكن الان
تم الانتقال الى مرحله اخرى وهي بناء
البيوت من الطوب في هذه المنطقه هناك
مشاريع يتم العمل عليها حاليا وهذه
المشاريع هي عباره عن بيت من طابق واحد
وهي ستسلم جزء كبير او قسم كبير من هذه
البيوت على الاقل 1000 1000 وحده سكنيه
تقريبا ستسلم في نهايه الشهر الحالي يتوقع
ان يستفيد من هذا المشروع
27 الف شخصا وبالتالي الان الافكار هي
تتجه الى ما بعد
الصدمه صدمه الزلزال الى كيف يمكن
المضيف الحياه في ظروف كهذا شكرا لك من
غازي عنتاب مراسلنا معتز بالله حسن